in just a few minutes after that a
couple of call-in opportunities brian
kill me to fox and friends tara west
over you'll hear from doris kearns
goodwin live
john meacham and lawrence wright full
schedule available at booktv.org this is
live coverage
[Music]
welcome everybody
i'm david moskowitz i'm head of
government relations and public policy
at wells fargo and i'm very pleased to
be here with you today we are pleased to
serve for the eighth year as a charter
sponsor of the book festival and even
prouder to watch the book festival grow
into the incredibly popular and
impactful event it has become in fact i
wouldn't be surprised
thank you
wouldn't be surprised to see us move the
needle on some best seller list today
but it's even more important to keep the
book festival a free event that serves
the community
the library of congress and the book
festival's real purpose here is literacy
which leads to learning and opportunity
which matches our goal of helping our
community succeed learning to love books
and learning to love learning are what
the book festival is all about
in this session ron sharnell will
discuss his biography of ulysses grant
if we're lucky certain other popular
founding fathers
one thing i learned from the story of
president grant was how people can
evolve and through persistence and hard
work acknowledge and overcome their
imperfections it's an incredible story
that reminded me of that a person of
goodwill can really learn from their
mistakes and reach their potential
i hope you enjoy this session now it's
my privilege to introduce the deputy
director of national international
outreach at the library of congress and
our session moderator colleen shogun
thank you
thank you
welcome to the 18th annual national book
festival
i'm pleased to be joined on stage today
by ron chernow ron is an award-winning
journalist historian and biographer he's
won the pulitzer prize for biography and
the national book award for non-fiction
in 2015 he won the national humanities
medal
his book on alexander hamilton was the
inspiration for the award-winning
musical for which ron worked as a
historical consultant the library of
congress is honored to have you join us
today at the national book festival
it's worth noting that uh our co-chair
of the festival mr david grubenstein was
supposed to conduct this interview today
but due to scheduling changes uh because
of senator mccain's funeral he was
unable to do so but i have david's
questions here today and i just happen
to be a big admirer of ulysses s grant
and ron's books uh so i think we're
going to have a fantastic time here
today at the book festival before we
talk about grant uh we need to ask a
question about alexander hamilton uh
how could we not
see
so when lin manuel miranda first
approached you and said that he wanted
to create a hip-hop musical based upon
your book
uh what was your reaction did you ever
think it would become a cultural
phenomenon well you know very often
colleen people say to me when you're
writing the alexander hamilton biography
did you have any idea that it would be
turned into a hip-hop musical and i
always think to myself i think the
question answers itself
when i first met uh lin-manuel miranda
which was back in the fall of 2008 lynn
was still starring in his first musical
in the heights and he asked me on the
spot to be the historical advisor to
this as yet non-existent show so i left
and i said to him you mean you want me
to tell you when something's wrong and
he said with great fervor he said yes i
want the historians to take this
seriously
which was music to my ears and i was i
was a little bit skeptical but i was
quite intrigued and i thought that
nothing could be more delightful than to
watch the evolution of a broadway
musical i was a lifelong theater goer
and he offered to be on the other side
of the footlights was absolutely
irresistible and of course it turned out
to be a rocket ride far far beyond
anything that i could have anticipated
so we'll move on to grant which you've
certainly written the definitive
biography of of grant and i have to
start with kind of a cute question but
it has a good story to it who's buried
in grants too
when i first started working on the book
which was in 2011
i found that approximately half the
people uh whom i told i was working on
grand shot back who's buried in grant's
tomb
so naturally i got very interested in
the origin of this joke well
i traced it back to groucho marx you can
trace everything back to grouch remarks
and groucho some of you are old enough
to remember had a quiz show in the 1950s
called you bet your life
and groucho was dismayed that so many of
the contestants could not answer a
single one of the questions so grouchy
decided that he would ask every
contestant the question that every
contestant
could answer and that question is who's
buried in grant's tomb to grouch's
astonishment half the guests got it
wrong
but such is the staying power of a great
comedian that the line has become part
of the popular culture
let's start at the beginning with grant
where was he born what were the
conditions of his upbringing what was
his family like he was born in point
pleasant ohio he grew up in a series of
small towns in southwestern ohio near
cincinnati and point pleasant was right
on the ohio river and the significance
of that was that
it separated the free state of ohio from
the slave-owning state of kentucky in
fact on winter evenings the ohio would
freeze over and refugee fugitive slaves
would sprint to freedom very important i
think in terms of thinking about grant
later with appomattox that he grew up
really uh straddling you know the world
of both north and south and understood
both of their cultures came from
actually fairly well to do family his
father was a rich tanner and mayor of
one of those uh three uh towns um and
his father was really the bane of his
life his father was a very pushy and
domineering character
and then grant went
to west point because grant wanted to go
to west point no he did not but his
father wanted him to go and his father
was kind of a skin flint who saw
west point as a free form of vocational
education
how did he do at west point actually
fairly well it was i would say his
performance was lackluster he was uh
21st in the class of
39 but there was already considerable
attrition before that
he became famous for two things at the
academy one was he was probably the best
horseman of his generation uh if not
century at the academy he established a
high jumping record on the source name
york they set the bar at more than five
feet and grant managed to clear it was a
record that
was not equal for many decades at the
academy he was also very good at drawing
now this may seem strange and
insignificant but
cadets were try drawing because it was
thought important for uh generals to be
able to draw maps during battles and
grant was very good at drawing and
during the civil war he had an uncanny
ability to visualize the uh battlefield
and it all comes from this very visual
sense that he had that was first
reflected in his uh capacity to draw
after west point he has a number of
assignments then he eventually ends up
as a quartermaster in the mexican war
why is his service as a quartermaster
why does that turn out to be important
extremely important um chris being
quartermaster in mexico gave grant a
nuts and bolts knowledge of the
logistics of an army and kind of looking
ahead to the civil war now grant would
be in charge of four or five different
armies stretched across a 1300 mile
front and so grant's mastery of
logistics his mastery of the railroad
and the telegraph really enabled him to
supervise these vast armies and it goes
back to being quartermaster and mexico
and also very
importantly as quartermaster grant was
not obligated to actually fight he could
have stayed behind the lines but he made
a point of volunteering to fight in
every single
combat that his troops were
involved in that's kind of real courage
that's real patriotism
after the mexican war he marries julia
dent and what was she like and what was
her family like okay so grant comes from
this abolitionist family in ohio he
marries into a slave-owning family in
missouri's father-in-law colonel
frederick dent the colonel was purely
honorific becomes the bane of his life
is very hard on grant
julia was very outgoing and uh vivacious
and julia
always had a vision of grant's future
that he sometimes did not have himself
during the 1850s he's trying and failing
to establish himself as a farmer in
saint louis and he fails at a real
estate venture and during this very
bleak period in grant's life
julia has a dream uh one night she
dreams that her present that her husband
is going to be president of the united
states and when she tells her friends
and family about the stream
everyone laughs nothing can seem more
preposterous this man is struggling just
to support a wife and for children
julian
you spend a fair amount in the book
talking about grant's struggle with
alcohol
what did you conclude did he have a
problem with drinking and what sort of
evidence did you use to draw those
conclusions well historically the debate
about grant has always been you know was
he a drunkard or not and i always found
just the term drunkard is such a kind of
loaded moralistic term because it
implies that a person who was dissipated
and irresponsible and was kind of
gleefully indulging this
vice
i felt that
i tried to approach it through what i
hope is our more enlightened attitude he
was he was an alcoholic i say that
because he could never have just one
drink i say that because even one glass
of alcohol changed his personality but
this was something that he struggled
against his entire life he was already a
member of a temperance lodge when he was
in his 20s the reason i think there's
been so much difficulty that previous
writers had with grant's drinking is
that
he was a binge drinker he was an
episodic drinker so that he could go for
two or three months without touching
glass of alcohol he would then have two
or three
day benders that even people work
closely with them would not actually see
him
during those breezes as they were
called and so but it's a problem that he
struggles with and by the time he
becomes president he's largely conquered
it but it certainly is a problem that
bedevils him throughout the civil war
right
uh and that causes him to leave the
military precipitates uh an exit from
the military yes in 1854 he was assigned
to a couple of very lonely bleak
garrisons in oregon northern california
where he could not afford to bring his
wife and children he was lonely he was
depressed he starts drinking and then in
1854 he shows up one day at a pay table
drunk and has really drummed out of the
surface service it was very significant
because the peacetime army was really
very small
and so there was a very active rumor
mill so all of the stories grant's
history of drinking
will follow him into the civil war and
will very much kind of color how people
uh see him i think that probably we're
not for that history and all of these
stories about grant's drinking uh
abraham lincoln might well have brought
grant east much sooner in the war to act
as general in chief
so now grant's a civilian and uh you
have a very poignant description of him
he ends up on the streets of saint louis
selling firewood to support his family
how does that happen
yeah okay try making it as a farmer
julia is a wedding gift from her father
and received 60 acres which grant worked
he was very industrious but he could not
make a go of it so he ends up taking a
firewood
it's 10 miles into st louis and he
actually walks beside the uh the wagon
people who saw him in those days selling
firewood on street corners in st louis
said that he was bearded disheveled
unkempt looking in fact one of his old
army buddies ran into him on the street
and was really shocked by grant's
unkempt appearance and he said to him
grant what are you doing grant's
response was very poignant he said i'm
solving the problem of poverty
he was so poor at that yeah he was so
poor at that point
uh that um one christmas he had to pawn
his watch to buy christmas presents for
his um family this was circa 1856
civil war breaks out 1861.
then something happens fort sumter and
you write in your book uh grant
eventually joins the volunteer infantry
in illinois and then gets a position in
the union army and you write in your
book that a change overcomes grant what
was that change well you know when the
civil war broke out there was a
desperate shortage of officers you have
to remember about um a third of the army
officers were from the south so many of
them most of them defected to the
confederacy so it was a crying need for
trained people
grant still had all of that lore from
west point stewart in his mind
he had fought with great distinction in
the mexican war had been assigned to
four different frontier garrisons um uh
before the the civil war and so
uh his efficiency
and his military knowledge immediately
come to the fore and so grant's rise
gives a new meaning to the term uh
meteoric
two months
after the outbreak of the civil war he's
a colonel
four months after it he's a brigadier
general
twelve months after the outbreak of the
civil war he's a major general
and by
the end of the civil war this man who
had been working as a clerk in his
father's leather good store in golian
illinois back in 1860 that man who had
seemed like a certifiable failure in
life was general in chief of the union
army with one million soldiers under his
command far and away the largest
military establishment in the country up
until that time
now he has some early victories that
catches the eye of lincoln is that right
yeah absolutely you know very often the
history of the civil war there's kind of
a disproportionate focus on virginia if
you look at virginia it seems like the
confederacy is winning battle after
battle if you look at what was happening
in the western theater of war grant was
winning one victory after another and in
early 1862 he has kind of twin battles
against twin forts all the way in the
northwest corner of tennessee forts
henry and uh
donaldson
they were significant for the following
reason of fort henry uh was on the
tennessee river fort cumberland on the
uh i'm sorry fort donelson on the
cumberland river and those two rivers
penetrated deep into the uh confederacy
particularly grant's victory at fort
donelson was the first of three times
that he captured an entire confederate
army more than 13 000 people it also led
to a new nickname for grant because the
confederate general inside the fort was
simon buckner who wanted sent a message
to grant he wanted commissioners
appointed to negotiate a truce and grant
wrote back you know no terms except
unconditional and immediate surrender
will be accepted i propose to move upon
your works immediately that
unconditional surrender line he became
instead of u.s grant he became
unconditional surrender uh grant it was
really kind of the first large-scale
victory of the war for the north
in late 1862 he issues general order
number 11 which expels the jews from his
military district in the south because
he believes that they're engaged in a a
illegal black market cotton ring that's
right and was grant anti-semitic or did
he regret that decision
he regretted it almost as as soon as he
issued it as soon as lincoln and
secretary war edwin stanton saw it they
immediately uh overrode it grant said
that he did regret it uh almost
instantly it was an atrocious and
inexcusable thing to do people know that
piece of the story you know what they
don't know is grant spent the rest of
his life atoning for that action as
president he appointed more jews to
public office than all the other 19th
century presidents combined he became
the first president to speak out on
human rights abuses abroad and in both
cases it was because of persecution of
the jews one time
in russia one time in poland then most
remarkable of all since we're sitting
here in washington dc during the um last
year of his second term
he was invited to the dedication of a
synagogue called adas isroel a very tiny
synagogue grant went with his son and
with
a u.s senator it was a three-hour
ceremony here he's president united
states this was a congregation probably
had 40 or 50 people
one hour into the dedication of this
synagogue
the elders of the synagogue went over to
grant said mr president were very
touched that you would come to this you
know humble
function you can leave now in good
conscience grant insisted on staying the
full three hours reached into his pocket
gave a donation
to the synagogue he was not um it was
kind of one of the pleasurable things
writing about him he was not a prejudice
man he was not a man you know full of
hatred you know you could read i don't
know say william comes to sherman his
statements on you know blacks or
native americans kind of hair-raising
ferocious things you don't see that in
grant's papers at all so this was
something that was really very out of
character for him and luckily he
apologized in the tone for it the rest
of his life
he has a number of other successes he
has more manpower at this time more
resources
and then he has the victory at vicksburg
why is vicksburg so impressive and why
it was really a daring capture yeah what
happened you know um new orleans baton
rouge and memphis had fallen to union
forces and it meant that the one great
citadel one great bastion on the
mississippi river left to the
confederacy was vicksburg vicksburg was
located at that time there was a bend in
the mississippi there that forced boats
to to slow down there were seven miles
of very elaborate fortifications so it
really seemed like this impregnable
fortress
grant had really a very daring strategy
to take uh vicksburg
under cover of night
he had iron clads and transports come
down the river despite heavy shelling
from the confederates he also marched
some troops down the western bank of the
mississippi
they then crossed over
south of vicksburg to the only high dry
land
in that area and then kind of grant us
this lightning campaign he wins
five major victories in a three-week
period
surrounds vicksburg lays siege to it and
vicksburg surrenders it was the same
time as the victory at gettysburg
and for a second time grant has captured
an entire confederate army of more than
30 000
soldiers and so at that point
the union not only controlled the
mississippi but it bisected the
confederacy because a lot of the
supplies particularly horses and
livestock came from west of the
mississippi so the confederate army was
suddenly cut off from this major source
of supplies west of the mississippi and
that was grant
when did president lincoln bring grant
east to lead the union army well what
happens in february 1864
congress passes a bill
reinstating the title of lieutenant
general the only one who had ever held
out was
george washington winfield scott had
kind of brevit lieutenant general uh and
grant becomes that lieutenant general
it's a wonderful story because in march
1864 he comes to washington although
lincoln loved grant he never actually
set eyes on him before
grant happened to arrive
at the
the same day that lincoln was having a
reception at the white house in the blue
room
and grant goes in lincoln warmly
embraces him and there was such
pandemonium in the room because grant
was such a hero that they urged grant to
stand up on a sofa so that people could
see him because he was relatively short
he stands up on the sofa he's
perspiring profusely
so that people could see him and grant
was always a little bit socially awkward
and grant later said that the hottest
campaign he ever fought was standing on
that sofa
in the white house
so grant was impressive on a tactical
level on an operational level and on a
strategic level how rare was that to
find all three qualities in a in a
general and how did he compare to robert
e lee in that regard
well um
sherman had a very interesting comment
where he was comparing uh grant and lee
uh he said that grand strategy embraced
a continent lee's strategy embraced
estate virginia that is um grant and i
had the harder task
lee just had to inflict so much pain
on union forces that the northern public
would weary and decide to give up the
war grant actually had to capture
destroy
robert e lee's
army and
he really had a strategic vision because
the various union armies in different
theaters of war had been operating
independently of each other grant
coordinated their movements
so that they he turned them into a
single uh fighting uh force and he saw
that the way to wear down the
confederacy was by having union forces
simultaneously attack
different confederate armies so that
they could not kind of switch
reinforcements from
one to another then he finally
pins robert e lee down in richmond and
petersburg and there's another wonderful
comment from sherman sherman said about
grant he said robert e lee would attack
the front porch she said
ulysses s grant would attack the bedroom
in the kitchen
i'm not sure what he meant about the
bedroom i don't want to go there
but in terms of attacking the kitchen
that again this goes back to grant the
quartermaster but he did with lee and
richmond petersburg is he began
systematically to cut off
every railway line in every canal that
was feeding supplies
to lee's army finally starving it out
and forcing him to flee west
appomattox courthouse where
grant and sheridan overtake lee's army
and force its surrender and that was
then the third
confederate army that grant captured
robert e lee never captured a single
union army how does grant conduct
himself at appomattox
oh it's the most touching part of the
story because he refuses to allow
his soldiers to gloat or celebrate
he's very generous these confederate
soldiers literally are starving he
issues rations to feed them
he allows the confederate officers to
keep their horses and firearms and
really i think the most beautiful
passage
in grant's memoirs
is about the meeting in appomattox
because grant said that
he was sad and depressed
when he met
lee and he writes i felt like anything
rather than rejoicing over the downfall
of a foe who had fought with such valor
um and uh suffered such hardship for a
cause although that cause was
the worst
that any you know army could have fought
for and i think it's a beautiful
statement particularly we've had a
prolonged discussion about the
confederate monuments and i think grant
in a way shows the way because on the
one hand in that passage
he play he pays homage to the bravery of
the confederate soldiers and they were
brave they were quite extraordinary in
many many battles at the same time the
cause for which they were fighting the
perpetuation of slavery was as grant
says one of the worst causes that people
fight for so i think that that the
humanity and also the fairness and
balance that he brought to that subject
i think is really one that should stay
with us
grant does not accept uh president
lincoln's invitation to attend ford's
theater
would history perhaps unfolded
differently if grant had been there yeah
it's quite a story because what happened
in late march 1864 abraham and mary
lincoln go down to city point virginia
where grant has his headquarters
um mary lincoln who has shown increasing
signs of mental instability
mary lincoln
throws a jealous fit she imagines that
the young wife
of general edward osiord is flirting
with her husband and she starts to
berate young mrs zord who can't figure
out what's going on and bursts into
tears and julia grant was there
julia grant intervened to try to
protect
young mrs zord and we all know what
happens when you try to intervene in the
middle of the fight
then mary lincoln turned on uh julia
grant
and turned on her so angrily that
um the night that the lincolns went to
ford theater
lincoln thought it was very important
that the public see the victoria's
president and the victorious general at
the same time
julia grant you know laid down the law
to her husband she said i refuse to go
to ford's theater if mary lincoln is
going to be there
so they made their you know excuses they
went off to burlington new jersey where
they had a house
so um one of the great what-ifs of
history
if
ulysses s grant had been in that box at
ford's theater with lincoln
would have had a security detail there
would with his military instincts he
have
sensed you know the assassin entering
the box or of course it's entirely
possible
that booth would have killed grant as
well as lincoln will never know
how did grant managed to win the
nomination the republican nomination in
1868
had he showed an aptitude for politics
previously
no not not really in fact there was kind
of a great guessing game that went on in
terms of what grant's party affiliation
uh uh was came from you know whig
families only vote had been for
james buchanan for president really no
one knew exactly where he uh stood he
was in the right place at the right time
you know since appomattox he had a
certain symbolic
uh standing in american life as as the
victor of the war and also
reconciliation
between north and uh south and what
happened 1868 there was a failed attempt
they did impeach president john andrew
johnson
is not convicted lost by a single vote
which weakened the radical republicans
in congress grant kind of was in a
position
uh to straddle both of the wings of the
republican uh
party uh still had this kind of immense
prestige from the uh the war and he did
not
campaign openly
for it grant had a funny kind of way
of not campaigning for things but sort
of putting him in a position
where things had just happened to happen
to him
in his first term of office the 15th
amendment is enacted
and ratified and there's a backlash in
the south uh violence escalates and
there's uh strengthening of the ku klux
klan
you spend a lot of time in the book and
you handle it very definitely what did
grant do to combat the klan and was he
successful yeah the clan starts in
pulaski tennessee 1866 it starts out as
a social club of confederate veterans
and they start you know wearing their
old uniforms and
drilling and it becomes a militaristic
uh secret organization and then of
course they start putting on you know
robes and hoods at night on horseback
and terrorizing people this was you're
absolutely right prompted by the 15th
amendment nothing terrified
the white south more than the black man
and it was only black men
voting and so the terror was very much
directed against blacks voting or
registering to vote
there was no southern sheriff who would
arrest a member of the clan uh there was
no southern jury that would convict a
member of the clan there was no southern
white who would testify against the clan
so there had been
there were hundreds maybe thousands of
murders of blacks that went unprosecuted
uh grant
all right a very uh crusading attorney
general named damas ackermann from
georgia
ackermann brought
3000
indictments i got more than a thousand
convictions uh against the klan and
crushed the ku klux klan i mean it was
his greatest achievement as president
the clan that we know
uh is really from the resurgence of the
clan from the 19 teens and 1920s that
clan that is the last deal with us and
they've chris borrowed a lot of the
um
techniques and ideology of the original
clan
why were there so many corruption
related scandals and grants two terms of
office did he was he complicit did he
turn a blind eye or was he just
oblivious to what was going on grant was
incredibly naive i'll tell the story
from his child but it makes the point
unfortunately
he didn't get much better when he when
he was a boy his uh father uh wanted to
buy a horse so he told uh ulysses to go
to this farm and he uh gave ulysses
instructions he said offer 20 to the
farmer uh if he doesn't take it then
what from 22-15 if he still doesn't you
know bite offer 25.
so grant goes to the farm and says my
father said i should offer you 20 for
the horse but if you don't take it to
offer you 20 to 15 if you don't take
that to offer 25 dollars well i wish i
could say there was some learning curve
in terms of grant and money but there
there wasn't and uh you know
unscrupulous uh people
uh seemed to spot grant a mile away in
fact during
his second term in office the so-called
whiskey ring scandal
the brewers were evading this tax by
paying off
revenue agents and one of the people who
was very involved in it was grant's
really chief of staff a man named oval
babcock
and
when babcock is being investigated grant
writes a letter to babcock's
wife saying i have full faith
in your husband's integrity said i've
had the most you know intimate and
confidential relations with your husband
for
14 years and he says i can't
believe
that he's not the trustworthy person
that i imagine guess what he he was and
as i said he was kind of like chief of
staff he had the desk right outside
grant's office reviewed incoming an
outgoing
mail
and um grant fired him while he assigned
him he became inspector of lighthouses
uh on the florida coast
so after he leaves office grant goes on
a trip around the world with his wife
for two and a half years how was he
received in this trip
it's kind of a post-presidency unlike
any other during that you know almost
two and a half year period um he meets
with virtually every head of state in
the world uh queen victoria receives him
at windsor castle
um
prince bismarck receives them in berlin
the pope at the vatican
is our alexander ii in saint petersburg
and then he goes to the far east and the
crowds are immense like 250 000 people
at a time
uh would uh turn out and even you know
the um the emperor of japan uh would
never actually touch
people when he saw a grant he stepped
forward and shook hands with grant which
was
unheard of and grant actually
pioneers a certain post-presidential
role that would be followed by other
presidents that he arbitrates
a dispute over post-war islands
offshore islands
between japan and uh china you know so
he comes back with really this sort of
great reputation uh very much uh
enhanced uh he's become a statesman
on the world stage it's amazing
after trying to get the nomination again
in 1880 not not winning it uh he decides
to move to new york city and try his
hand in the investment world how does
that turn out well again money
disastrously you know
question answers itself he formed a
partnership
with a young man named ferdinand ward
who's 29 years old who was lionized as
the young napoleon
finance
they created a partnership called grant
and ward it was the only time grant ever
allowed his name to
be used in business and of course
grant's name attracted a lot of money
alas for those of you don't know the
story ferdinand ward was the bernie
madoff of the day it was a it was a
ponzi scheme he was using money from new
investors to pay outrageous rates of
interest to the old investors and so
poor
grant with this incurable naivete grant
imagines
that he's a multimillionaire and he
wakes up one day to find out that
instead of being a multi-millionaire
he's worth eighty dollars and julia's
worth a hundred thirty dollars
that not only had grants um uh
fortunately what was his fortune uh been
wiped out but you know all of his
children had invested with madoff he had
a lot of cousins he had a lot of
friends so the entire
grand family was engulfed in this
catastrophe
in 1884 grant falls ill what was wrong
with him and what was the prescribed
treatment right now this the illness um
really coincides with the exposure of
the problem
with
for dan
ward grant one day they had a house in
longbranch new jersey
julia serves him a plate of delicious
peaches and he bites
into one of the peaches and says ouch
that peach stunned me for some reason
and it was the first time he realized
there was a problem
with his throat he finally with some
delay consulted his doctor in new york
who found a cancerous mass
on his throat and
tongue it was
incurable
and so
grant realized that this was a terminal
illness and he was petrified
that not if but really when he died
that julia would be left destitute
because they'd lost all their money so
he decided to do something that he's
worthy wouldn't do he wrote his memoirs
so during the last year of his life in
excruciating pain
and with his mind often fogged by the
opiates he managed to
write a memoir that is considered the
greatest military memoir
probably in english language he wrote 10
000 words in a day while he had throat
cancer yeah and his publisher was mark
twain and one wonderful letter you know
uh mark twain writes to somebody grant
wrote ten thousand words today so it
kills me these days to even write five
thousand words in a in a day couldn't
believe grant's uh productivity and this
memoir really poured
uh out of him and many people imagine
that twain uh wrote the the memoirs
train wrote their style is flawless no
man can improve upon them
why is grant buried in new york city and
what was his funeral like yeah because
the last few years of their lives uh uh
ulysses and julie grant were living on
east 66th street uh in manhattan his
funeral i was just thinking about his
funeral today because of the
john mccain
memorial gathering at national cathedral
when grant was buried
in new york and that he and julia felt
very grateful to
new york and the city provided this
beautiful spot
in the new riverside park
grant's funeral
spoke to the public very much in the way
that john mccain's memorial services
have been speaking to the public that is
at grant's
funeral a million and a half people
flooded new york city the funeral parade
went on for five hours but
grant and his family made a statement
so it was of north south reconciliation
there were
as among the honoree polar bears there
were great union generals william
tecumseh sherman and phil sheridan but
there were also major confederate
generals joseph johnston and simon uh
buckner
um
again as part of this reconciliation
theme the stonewall jackson brigade from
staunton virginia came up and marched in
the parade black regiments marched in
the parade because grant had been very
instrumental during the civil war in
terms of recruiting and training and
equipping you know black soldiers and so
this was really
grant's final statement from beyond the
grave and i think that uh you know grant
in many ways
reminds me what people have been saying
about john mccain in terms of his
patriotism
his
bravery
uh his dedication to public service the
fact that he distinguished himself both
in civilian service and and military
service and kind of reminds us of what
old-fashioned patriotism should look
like
last question before we take some
questions from the audience
as we reconsider grant as you have in
this magnificent book what should we
learn from grant in his leadership
well i think that one reason people have
responded to the book you know all the
other people that i've written about um
were seem to be instant successes in
life they were sort of built for success
that kind of great drive and energy and
focus grant uh didn't and i think people
are responding to the book because
the highs are as high as any story in
american history but the lows are a lot
lower you know so this is a story with a
lot of light and shadow
it's a story about a man who suffered
repeated failures and uh setbacks uh in
fact as i was coming into the to the
room someone said to me i loved your
grant because it's the greatest story
about a comeback and there were repeated
comebacks in graham's uh life you know
success was kind of a greasy pull and he
keeps slipping back down the pole and
then he would have to work his way back
up again terrific if there are any
questions uh for ron would be happy to
take a few um
um hello uh
a very good book
loved it i just want to ask a quick
comment on grant's relationship with
george armstrong custer and how you
described
that relationship in the book it was a
very it was very troubled uh
relationship and uh grant was
very very
uh critical
of
custer really blamed custer for the
massacre at a little bighorn felt that
he was really you know not following um
orders and you know
put himself uh and his
men in harm's way custer also had been
an outspoken critic of grant as
president and that certainly helped to
fuel the animosity
i'm going to have
who we even because
my speech
yeah so i'm gonna read two questions uh
by becky true um if grant had gone by
his first name would anything be
different
secondly what is happening with the
adapt adaptation i know someone bought
the rights right good question okay
first you know grant's name he was born
hiram ulysses grant
which gave him the unfortunate initials
h.u.g or hug
and he was mercilessly teased by the
other boys so he dropped the
uh hiram and became just plain uh
ulysses then when
local congressman nominated him for west
point he bundled the name he centered in
his ulysses s grant actually found one
letter where ulysses is writing to julia
who wanted to know what the s did for
his own wife didn't know what it stood
for he wrote back his funny letter and
says the s stands for absolutely nothing
in terms of uh yeah the um it's not
going to be hip-hop musical um
shucks
um but it will be a feature film and
it's going to be uh directed by steven
spielberg which is very exciting
um and uh
produced by leonardo dicaprio which is
also exciting
uh and it looks like i'll again be the
historical consultant yeah they're great
[Applause]
um so you've written about washington
and hamilton and now grant are there any
lessons or a big lesson that you've
learned through studying these that
you think is
worth sharing oh it's a very very good
question you know one strange thing um
when people have asked me about a common
denominator to these lives um
the one thing and every person that i've
written about
they had to cope from an early age with
a difficult even impossible parent i
know this sounds like a strange response
to your question
but you know there was washington with
the very self-centered mother there was
hamilton with the absentee fraud grant
had this very
domineering and overbearing father and i
think that there's something about
coping with a very very difficult parent
that i guess shapes character
and forces people to be self-reliant at
an early age kind of big frustration i
found with all of these books is that
all the people i've written about
because they had such difficult parents
they never talked about it and sometimes
i imagine enough like if i could conjure
them to life and ask them questions i
think i'd want to zero in on the
family dynamics
grant was partnered with a ponzi s a
ponzi schemer didn't he play any part in
touching him
the ferdinand wood
i'm sorry i'm not sure that i answered
the question that was partnered with a
ponzi schemer ferdinand ward did you
play any part in touching him
well
and catch him did he catch him help
catch him no would that he had
you know what happened grant was
inexcusably complacent that um
ferdinand ward put all of the securities
of the firm in this safe to which only
ferdinand ward had access grant should
never have allowed that brendan woodward
even put letters you know
signed by grant in front of grant and
grant would sign them without reading
the uh the letter grant felt because
there were a lot of um sophisticated
wall street people
who were investing with uh
award that he was absolutely certain you
know that reward must be
sound he should have been
suspicious because some of the people
who are getting like 15 20 percent per
month you know boy if that doesn't raise
you know warning flags what did but i
wish that i could tell you that uh grant
had been uh part of exposing a ward uh
but was was was not what happened was
that the bank that was lending ward
money
went bust and then the whole scheme blew
up we have time for one more question
someone whose legacy has been unjustly
tarnished what has it been like to write
this overdue exploitation of grant yeah
it's been you know very very nice
because when i published the book on uh
uh grant uh i felt that you know he was
suffering from this image that he was
just this crude brutal butcher and that
was why he was a
successful uh
general and
in fact you know there were six union
generals
who fought against robbie lee before uh
grant with the same advantage in
manpower material they could not defeat
lee grant could i feel that gran's
presidency had been portrayed as a
failed presidency and i think that in
many ways it was a very successful
presidency in terms of protecting the
african-american community in the south
to the extent of the book you know
had a revisionist bent i thought there
would be more resistance and yet people
kind of accepted the portrait of grant
more readily than i thought would happen
so i'm happy for that although i was a
little surprised
please join me in thanking mr ron turner